eight on your side tonight people who
have been receiving unemployment
benefits for months now are wondering if
they'll see just another payment a lot
of people contacting our newsroom to see
if they're still eligible for money
because apparently it appears they are
on their portal joe moeller looked into
it and he joins us now with what he's
learned joe and denise the confusion
with the unemployment portal is causing
a lot of frustration you see money in
that portal but you don't know if you're
going to be getting that people say
getting through to dieter would help
many understand what exactly is going on
i don't know anything let's just put it
simply charles lewis is one of many
unemployment claimants looking for
answers i believe that i am behind
two
going on three weeks lewis says his
portal still shows money that is there
fundamental situation is a lack of
communication
from dieter unable to get answers lewis
reached out to 8 news now the department
tells us just because money is listed on
your portal does not mean you are
approved for that money you are eligible
for it if you meet the requirements
remember dieter is now back to the
regular ui requirements set before the
pandemic i have an open claim
and
that claim
has not been
it's not being addressed dieter tells us
to be eligible for benefits right now in
october of 2021 you must have worked for
a certain amount of time between july
2020 and june 2021
the issue many are running into as they
have not worked during the pandemic
so they are not eligible as pandemic
related extensions ended september 11th
lewis says his biggest issue is trying
to get through to dieter with his
questions so all of a sudden they cut
your phones off you're done no
communication
so that's a fundamental problem
dieter tells us anyone looking for a job
can use employeenv.gov that is where you
can find assistance with resumes and
applications and learn about training
for in-demand careers reporting in
studio this evening joe muller live
local now